MARKIPLIER: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Don't Escape 4.
This is the last day we have in the wasteland,
and I apologize for the delay in between these videos,
I've had a lot that I needed to get done,
before I leave to go home to LA.
But now...
we are back in the thick of it.
Aaand everything's locked because we were still at the storm.
So, this is the last day.
This is the day,
that we will ordinarily make our journey over to...the base, and then we will go up
zzyooOOom into the sky and we will try
not to die.
Whether we do or not is gonna be a conundrum.
Also I seem to be kinda low on fuel,
and also I should make sure I have everything that I need before I do it.
I'll be right back, gimme one second.
Okay! So I now got the shovel, the fuel which I'm gonna use to refuel, I've got the ID card which I'm gonna need, I have the gun, I have the silencer, I oddly enough don't have the scope, but I think that's gonna be okay.
So I'm gonna leave as many things as I can in the truck pad as possible,
I know I'm gonna need to gather more stuff later and I'll save a spot for that.
let's fuel this u- oooooohhh shit
ok so we gotta go get fuel for this first
that's gonna take some time but its best we do that because we gonna need to run around anyway
and if we go out there we will be out of fuel already and we won't be able to do that
so let's just go get fuel
Ok!